la fase de alarma que este jueves
anunció el gobierno alemán es la segunda
de tres fases que forman parte del plan
de emergencia alemán para garantizar el
suministro de gas el anuncio de esta
segunda fase responde de manera muy
particular a los recortes de gas ruso en
especial a través del gasoducto nord
stream 1 recortes que el gobierno alemán
no dudó en calificar como un ataque
económico de parte del gobierno ruso
vladímir putin
esta segunda fase pretende por un lado
fomentar el almacenamiento de gas un
tema relevante de cara a los meses de
otoño y de invierno pero también
fomentar una reducción en la demanda y
todo esto se enmarca por supuesto en el
plan del gobierno del canciller olaf
scholz de reducir la dependencia
energética de alemania hacia rusia un
tema por el cual alemania ha sido
criticada fuertemente en los últimos
meses
jova
el vice canciller y el ministro de
economía explicó al anunciar esta
segunda fase que la situación extensa
que ya se puede hablar incluso de una
crisis del gas pero que en el caso
particular de alemania- el suministro de
gas continúa garantizado